from wars in the past wars in the
present and even wars in the far-flung
future call of duty has been there but
the juggernaut franchise first made its
mark with one of the biggest events of
the 20th century world war ii an era it
has revisited multiple times over the
years since including its latest entry
call of duty vanguard let's look back at
the history of the world war ii call of
duty games
[Music]
1998's saving private ryan was huge and
its success popularized the world war ii
setting in games birthing huge
franchises like battlefield and medal of
honor in the early noughties activision
seeing the buzz decided it wanted its
own medal of honor and who better to
make it than 2015 studios developer of
2002's medal of honor allied assault
a few of the 2015 team were unhappy with
their contract with the game's publisher
ea and decided to leave to form a new
studio called infinity ward headed up by
vince ampella grant collier and jason
west infinity ward secured funding from
activision which bought a 30 share in
the studio and set out to make a game
that was codenamed moh killer
[Music]
despite the name though the infinity
ward team didn't just want to make a
medal of honor clone where the
protagonist was some sort of super
soldier who the fate of the war depended
on in its earliest incarnation call of
duty followed a james bond type spy
character who was given a super secret
mission to take down the nazi regime the
team ultimately decided to have three
playable characters so this idea was
dropped the story was split into three
campaigns british american and soviet
allowing players to experience some of
world war ii's most infamous battles
like the battle of stalingrad from
different perspectives its narrative was
delivered mostly through pre-mission
briefings
the invasion of europe will take place
across five main beaches along the
normandy coast of france and was overall
relatively sparse in terms of meaningful
characters and plot points outside of
the battles your characters don't even
speak but the game did feature some top
tier voice talent like jason statham
well head east destroying any targets of
opportunity then we'll meet up with the
rest of the squad as planned as well as
introduce fan favorite character captain
price
we can use it to hold the bridge until
our relief shows up
infinity ward really wanted to deliver
on the fact that wars were won by
soldiers working together and not by
one-man armies one way in which they did
this was by not having a sprint making
each approach a slow intense affair call
of duty was all about brotherhood and
working together with your squad the dev
team was made up of history buffs and
they drew upon their own knowledge and
undertook vast amounts of research to
ensure that the weapons vehicles and
artillery were accurate to the time
period even going so far as to record
weapons firing and reloading in real
life to use in the game to increase
immersion if a grenade or explosion went
off near you your character would
experience shell shock where the audio
would be muffled and your vision blurred
the attention to detail steered infinity
ward well call of duty launched on pc in
october 2003 to critical acclaim
gamespot awarded it a 9 out of 10 with
reviewer greg casavin saying that it
pulls together many of the best aspects
of other similar games and also includes
all sorts of little wish list items that
may have crossed your mind while playing
those other games the result seems above
all very well designed it received much
praise for its multiplayer particularly
the inclusion of the killcam which upon
death allowed you to see the pov of the
player who killed you
shortly after call of duty launched
activision bought the remaining 70 of
infinity ward and the team set to work
on the sequel
but before we saw call of duty 2 we got
united offensive an expansion pack made
by gray mata interactive and pie studios
it added new single player missions as
well as more multiplayer content once
again the campaign was split up into
three and while the levels were
relatively straightforward they were
bigger and offered more variety to the
gameplay greymata added bombastic
on-rails action sequences including one
on a plane and one with a gunboat
overall the game had a faster more
modern feeling pace there was sprinting
new weapons like flamethrowers and the
ability to cook grenades multiplayer saw
a number of new additions including new
maps a ranking system and game modes
including domination and capture the
flag and while single player may have
had on rails missions multiplayer
offered a little more freedom by letting
you drive meaning you could cross those
bigger maps with ease
and while we waited for a fully fledged
sequel call of duty made its first
appearance on console with finest hour
releasing on ps2 gamecube and the
original xbox it was based on the
original game once again featuring a
campaign from three different povs it
fared okay on the older hardware but
finest hour wasn't exactly the best
looking game especially compared to the
original game on pc and it had some
design quirks like a lack of checkpoints
and impossible to predict grenade tosses
however it did work harder to establish
a more gripping and personal narrative
developer spark unlimited even pulled in
brian johnson from ac dc to play
sergeant starkey [ __ ] your guns wet your
sights and ride on finest hour had mixed
reviews on launch but sold over a
million copies in just under a year in
2005 spark filed a lawsuit against
activision for 10 million dollars
accusing activision of fraud
misrepresentation and breach of contract
claiming that activision threatened to
pull funding a finest hour unless spark
agreed to take a lower royalty rate on
the game spark also filed an injunction
to try to prevent the release of call of
duty big red one activision ended up
counter-suing claiming monumental
incompetence from spark as of 2007 the
lawsuit was unresolved with spark going
on to make lost planet 3 with capcom the
developer eventually closed down in 2015
[Music]
when it became clear that halo 3 would
not hit the launch window of the xbox
360 microsoft reached out to activision
to see if they could make a sequel to
call of duty for the launch of its new
next generation console infinity ward
gleefully accepted and the team expanded
to ensure that both the xbox 360 and pc
versions of the game would hit the
deadline call of duty 2 was released in
late 2005 for pc and as an xbox 360
launch title once again the campaign was
split into multiple points of view with
developer infinity ward referring to
missions as vignettes instead of a
linear approach players were given the
chance to play through the war
chronologically or by following each of
the four playable characters through
their vignettes infinity ward began work
on cod 2 shortly after the first game
shipped and for the sequel they went all
out taking what worked in the original
and making it bigger and better there
were more levels and it used a new more
powerful game engine to make them bigger
and more detailed this was actually a
huge risk as during development the team
wasn't exactly 100 sure on what the 360
would be capable of so their game maxed
out the theoretical specs that they'd
been given it paid off as some effects
like smoke made the game look incredible
upon launch showing that the next
generation had truly arrived
there were multiple objectives and the
reins were loosened on the player so you
could tackle them in whichever order and
way you liked there was an even bigger
emphasis on squad missions meaning that
the friendly and enemy ai was vastly
improved enemy ai would work harder to
flank you and friendlies used something
called battle chatter to inform you of
what was happening around you
the game did include regenerating health
but removed the sprint that had been
introduced in united offensive
multiplayer built on the groundwork of
the previous titles bringing back fan
favorite modes like deathmatch and
adding a new one headquarters on xbox
360 you were able to play 4 player split
screen multiplayer and on xbox live the
multiplayer was limited to just 8
players which made the large maps feel a
bit empty call of duty 2 became the
biggest selling xbox 360 launch title
with over 80 percent of launch 360
owners also picking up a copy of the
game it looked like the moh killer was
well and truly picking up steam
if you hadn't quite upgraded to a
next-gen 360 in 2005 but still wanted to
play the latest cod you could get call
of duty 2 big red one for the original
xbox gamecube and playstation 2.
co-developed by gray mata interactive
and treyarch its campaign chronicled the
adventures of the us army's first
infantry division through the eyes of a
rookie private as they battle around the
world during the war its story was
delivered mostly in-game which meant
that big red one felt more quickly paced
and it offered a variety of missions
that weren't just go here shoot those
enemies press forward it got middling
reviews but received praise for its
variety of missions and its voice cast
which features mark hamill who
coincidentally was in a film called the
big red one by august of 1944 following
their success over the merciless german
defenders on omaha beach and a number of
actors from band of brothers including
bol okay let's set up a perimeter asap
skip
and guanine
keep looking at me okay you're gonna be
fine stay with me
by this point call of duty had become
annualized and with infinity ward hard
at work on call of duty 4 modern warfare
the first card not set during the second
world war treyarch stepped up to make
call of duty 3. allegedly made in just
eight months the game followed british
polish canadian and american soldiers
through the events of the normandy
breakout the weeks-long push that
allowed the allies to recapture paris
towards the end of the war with treyarch
revealing that the game had been built
from the ground up for next gen it came
with a bunch of improvements like a
better physics engine destructible
environments and multiplayer that could
handle up to 24 players rather than the
paltry 8 from call of duty 2.
it was small cinematic featuring close
combat sequences and quick time events
to struggle free from the grasp of enemy
soldiers it looked and sounded great
especially when connected to a surround
sound system our reviewer at the time
even said it was some of the best sound
work in any game to date
[Music]
[Applause]
gameplay-wise it didn't exactly reinvent
the wheel but it was a solid entry
caller gt3 was a launch title for the
ps3 with some features specifically made
to use its six-axis motion controls
interestingly it doesn't have trophies
because they just weren't a thing yet
but
it didn't come out on pc instead
launching on just about everything else
including last gen consoles and the wii
it was perceived as kind of a slap in
the face to the pc players who had been
with the series since the start the wii
version shipped without multiplayer and
had a pretty unwieldy control scheme all
in all the game was still a success
selling over two million copies in just
three months
they found us they're right behind me
get on the machine gun
roads to victory is a psp exclusive game
developed by amaze entertainment because
if medal of honor was on the psp call of
duty was going to be on the vsp god damn
it admittedly it wasn't that great but
then again most first-person shooters
struggle when on handheld consoles in an
attempt to be more comfortable to play
roads to victory offer different control
schemes a pretty over enthusiastic auto
aim
and dumbed down ai
but ultimately it was pretty buggy and
the game's lack of checkpointing meant
that frequently progress would be
completely lost due to the game crashing
grab a rifle we're gonna tear this place
apart
robot signal the strike team
technically the first game in the black
ops continuity world at war returned
players to world war ii after a year off
with an all-star cast featuring kiefer
sutherland miller
you're okay
thank god and gary oldman who would go
on to reprise his role in 2010's black
ops the heart of this army
its campaign was split between the
americans at the pacific theater and the
soviets on the eastern front new to the
series was the ability to play the
campaign with friends with each having
the same objective and even compete for
high scores cod multiplayer was
revolutionized with modern warfare and
in world of war it well and truly found
its groove with experience points perks
and kill streaks rewarding players at
every turn and making for a truly
intoxicating experience but world at
war's biggest contribution to the card
formula was the introduction of zombies
a co-op wave based survival mode that
sees players repelling waves of nazi
zombies it was unlocked after completing
the main campaign zombies was made late
in the development schedule some
developers were toying around with the
idea and implemented it in the game the
team realized they were onto something
it was addictive and a really fun
release from the heavy themes of the
campaign in its initial form it was
pretty bare bones but in later games
there was lore easter eggs and puzzles
eventually becoming its own full
standalone mode call of duty world at
war final fronts was released for
playstation 2 developed by british team
rebellion unfortunately it was hamstrung
by power limitations on the old console
and suffered from poor ai and outdated
graphics
and then we had a break from world war
ii in cod for almost a decade the
franchise at this point was still
annualized and in the meantime we
cracked the numbers mason
paid our respects and had a cool dog pal
but over time the actual gameplay of
card got weirder and floatier it was a
far cry from the no one man armies ethos
that infinity ward held strong to in
advanced warfare you could even wall run
in 2017 it was time for a change and we
got our boots on the ground in call of
duty world war ii
[Applause]
[Music]
now developed by sledgehammer games a
studio that had cut its teeth working
with infinity ward on modern warfare 3
world war ii removed the gamier parts of
card like regenerating health and double
jumps and its campaign was far more
mature than anything cod had touched
before even featuring nazi concentration
camps and showing the atrocities of war
its multiplayer also saw numerous
changes and additions like a new class
system called divisions a social hub
space called headquarters and a new game
mode called war similar to battlefield's
rush the multi-phased mode sees one team
attempt to conquer areas on a huge map
while the other defends
zombies was also included in the 10-year
gap since the previous world war ii
based call of duty the franchise had
become the juggernaut we think of it as
today world war ii earned a billion
dollars in just under two months and on
its launch weekend doubled the amount of
money made by the previous entry
infinite warfare in the same time span
it was clear that players had missed the
world war ii setting
something's not right
oh my god
holy [ __ ]
god damn heroes out of nowhere they're
on our torpedo bombers fighters aren't
here yet seventeen get on those bandits
which brings us to call of duty vanguard
once again helmed by sledgehammer its
storyline follows four soldiers as they
come together to form what later became
known as a special forces team each
member of the squad brings their own
unique skills and you get to play out
their backstories before the four all
come together to take out a nazi train
convoy it hits something of a middle
ground between boots on the ground
realism and the one man army feel of
some of the more modern cards our
reviewer phil hornshaw called it call of
duty's take on something like the
expendables on top of its multiplayer
mode vanguard has also made changes to
the immensely popular battle royal mode
war zone adding new weapons as well as a
new map called caldera
so there you have it the history of the
world war ii cod games if you liked this
video make sure to give it a thumbs up
and subscribe and let us know if you
want us to do a history of the other
card games too thanks so much for
watching
[Music]
you